so same thing here there's Stellan you
know he's the great father over the
family and these these kids are they're
kind of like the Soviet equivalent of
Cub Scouts they're sort of worshipping
Him and then I really like the other one
on the on the right because I mean you
could hardly find a more hellish
representation of a tyrant than that
right I mean it looks and this is quite
interesting it looks like Stalin is
standing in front of a mandorla chasm
and Orla is a shape like this an almond
shape you see that in Renaissance art
all the time it's an extremely old
symbol it's the oldest symbol that
people have ever found evidence for and
the thing is on fire it's like Stellan
there he is king of hell and it's
exactly right you know it's it's it's
eerie that that's the mode of
representation that emerged for them but
it's certainly accurate so you know the
whole tyrannical end of the great
fathers this is the sort of thing that
results from it you know it's like the
the elevation of the person at the top
of the door minutes are key to the
status of some kind of quasi deity
certainly happened in Hitler's case and
then the brutal murderous nough that can
emerge from that those are pictures from
the concentration camps at the end of
World War two so you know so I told you
that the feet the feminine can be rep
that terrible unknown things can be
represented by the feminine sort of a
monstrous figure you know but it's
certainly the case that the monstrosity
of culture is roughly equivalent to the
monstrosity of nature you know and one
of the things you might think about is
that common ideologies tend to utilize
these symbolic categories it's almost as
if they appropriate them so the
environmental movement for example
basically says benevolent nature right
so that's the positive feminine negative
culture because that's cultures out
there rapaciously destroying the
pristine wilderness of Mother Nature and
the negative individual too because you
know human beings are part of that as
individuals and we're kind of a cancer
on the face of the planet if you you
know I mean that's a pretty dark way of
looking at it obviously but it's
one-sided because you can easily say
yeah well you know we're in a war with
nature because obviously she's trying to
kill us
fast as possible and we better have some
culture because otherwise we'd be
sitting outside in the freezing snow and
you know you might be a rapacious
consumer but on the other hand you're
just trying to survive and it's not that
easy and so you know you need to have
both of those stories together before
you have a reasonable representation of
the world it's not easy to cope with
something like well like that it's not
easy to cope with something like that
and every institution has this potential
and this element because institutions
tend towards bureaucratization and
tyranny as they develop they close up
and become rigid and so you know that's
a rough thing to deal with and then of
course this is a rough thing to deal
with too so you might think well you
could have a little bit of sympathy for
human beings not just throw them in the
horrible rapacious creature category
which i think is an extraordinarily
pathological and also a pre genocide
'old thing to do you know because you
hear environment two lists for example
now and then say the planet would be
better off without people on it it's
like well you know that's kind of what
Hitler thought as well about certain
kinds of people anyways and god only
knows where he would have stopped so you
know when someone says something like
that one of the things you might think
is you should take a good look at your
unconscious structure there bucko
because fundamentally you're you know
there's a genocide 'el ideology at the
bottom of your thought structure and you
know you might think that you're an
environmentalist but you're actually
possessed by a genocidal ideology and
you better do something about that
because if you ever get any power you're
gonna be one dangerous creature